this is clearly not a punishment from a
teacher at school but the ferrara candy
company because they clearly instructed
bart to tell the kids butterfingers were
one of the four food groups in one of
their commercials
by this point we're late in season four
and have seen almost 100 episodes and in
almost all of them bart slams onto the
roof of this car there should be a lot
more damage here by this point and homer
should have learned his lesson
and for those of you who say it's the
same moment just shown over and over
bart's coming from writing a different
thing on the chalkboard every time
to human misery the toast at the end of
every cinemasin staff meeting somehow
makes its way into this episode
mcbain is not dead from hypothermia in
this scene if all these guys pulled guns
out at the same time how do none of them
get a shot off before mcbain fires
something tells me this movie parody
within a satire show is choosing to play
loose with logic
contaminating the punch it's just a
movie son
there's nobody that evil in real life
[Laughter]
burns has to hold down a button to use
the intercom but somehow smithers
intercom is hands-free
whoa what the hell how did no one notice
this obvious obstruction earlier in the
game
bane would be so disappointed in your
shoddy work also this ball hits him in
the head a good three seconds after he
tripped meaning this pass was severely
underthrown
so the sin as always is carson wins the
big book
of british smiles that's british
here's lisa today without treatment
here's what she'll look like at age 11.
show pretends that its characters will
ever age just a reminder if the kids had
aged lisa would turn
40 this year we can stick her in a
trailer drive around the south and
charge two bits of gander
underselling your freak sister it's the
logo that slays me
simpson's sign jokes are the best lisa
needs braces
dental plan lisa needs braces when i say
this goes on for all the some time i
mean it goes on for 28 seconds
and no the joke with the guy dropping
the pencil in homer's butt crack does
not subtract from the amount of time it
takes
only using the center square in your
giant tv mosaic when it doesn't feature
whoopi goldberg or
paul lind i move that homer simpson be
our new union president
all in favor no one seconds to motion
and the question is not called
carl you're out of order this whole
meeting is out of order
lisa and marge these braces are
invisible painless
not pictured invisible braces well i
mean technically they are pictured but
aren't invisible or else they wouldn't
be pictured
my point is i can see the freaking
braces doctor we don't have a dental
plan right now
but why homer tore up the new contract
before it was ever approved shouldn't
everyone still be operating under the
old contract until a new one is put in
place
can you get this sugar daddy off my back
in the previous scene we saw homer's
back clearly and there was no sugar
daddy on his shirt
also naming your candy sugar daddy also
also
sugar daddies does lisa trip balls more
than any other character on the simpsons
between this the selma's choice episode
where she drinks the water at duff
gardens and the one where she becomes a
vegetarian
lisa is always on something joe doesn't
know the difference between purple and
yellow
if this buzzard looks this much like mr
burns does that mean mr burns has
had relations with the buzzard this is
terrible ping pong storage etiquette if
you're gonna leave the paddles out leave
one on each side
and never i repeat never leave a
ping-pong ball on the table i don't have
time to go into the details but trust me
you don't want that pain in your life
and now they're gone kid and play
cosplay cause and play
come on honey smile calling a female
honey and asking her to smile
sorry buddy i know it's part of your job
but then's the rules come gather
round children it's high time he learns
folk music so i tied an onion to my belt
which was the style at the time i swear
there are more simpsons quotes from
these early episodes that live on today
than the entirety of the rest of
television combined
so of course i'm going to now sin all
the other shows for not being this good
it's okay setting things that don't
deserve it is a victimless crime like
punching someone in the dark
how does this dog poop
taking the kicking the dog trope
literally this instant looting as soon
as the power goes out it's one of the
best simpsons gags ever
look at them all through the darkness i
am bringing they're not sad at all
they're actually singing the spit is so
perfect i can't help but grin
so despite my cold heart i'll remove one
more sin
i noticed you have braces i have of two
sinners go vows to our newest domain of
nifty delights and behold commercial
sins
oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click sub simple as that
oh actually watch the video jesus i
guess i need to make a flow chart
commercial sans go now
you are not sending me to the cooler
mania
when the madness melt the mania
i am talking about macho madness and
hulkamania
and this happy little fellow is the
gouger
relief discomfort of which of these i
next apply
that decision is in your hands
who is it telegram
it's high time he learns about a hero
named homer and a devil named burns